i'm curious i mean when the opportunity
to be a part of this show came your way
what was it that most appealed to you
was it mindy kaling was it the subject
matter was it your specific character
were you just hoping that you would get
to attend a naked party at least once
during the season like what what what it
was all like literally all three of
those things yeah it was
i mean it was everything and the naked
party too like so forth
but it was all of that it was like oh my
gosh
uh sex
girls insects and mindy kaling and funny
and what
yeah i think i was really fascinated and
like
interested in the relationships of the
four girls and i thought it was just
funny that they're all so different and
thrown into this space and have to
navigate like becoming friends and that
it happens in such a natural way
um in such a funny way and also that
they have so much agency over their
sexuality and their sexual experiences
and i feel like that's something that i
was really
excited about and something that i
rarely see
and especially in this age of young
women
i was i was excited too because like
reading the pilot
um
and i i loved how i i loved the title um
but i reading the pilot the comedy is so
dry and so strong on the page like
standing alone um like we wouldn't even
really have to do much and it would be
funny um and so i was like okay this
will be fine like there's room to play
um and also like again like even if i
don't do something right like it might
still be funny
out there
um yeah no but it's it's the writer's
room is uh really strong that pilot is
damn good on paper
yes the pilot is phenomenal i didn't
actually read the pilot until we got
cast all i knew was uh the script the
audition sides that hannah wrote hannah
levin was justin's assistant who's also
a phenomenal writer but just having a
brown girl that's sexual on screen was
it very exciting to me and saying all
the nasty things that she says and like
i've never seen a brown girl say those
crazy things on screen before how is she
even allowed to do the sauna
so that was all very very exciting to me
yeah i mean i just love how these are
even though all these girls are a mess
in their own way
they still
embrace who they are they're not making
apologies for who they are or what
they're doing or exploring and and
there isn't so much of that guilt that
it seems like they feel like they have
to put into the character you know a lot
of shows feel like they have to put some
level of guilt in to make it all seem
better or something and i just love how
there's a celebration on this show yeah
yeah that's not about i i think that's
one of something that the four of us had
so much fun doing was being able to
explore
um
the character sexuality or the
character's relationship to sex
uh in very distinct ways and feel that
there was a nice support system behind
it because they're you're living with
these other girls um who go about it so
differently
so i think that was definitely like a
big
like
there was real attraction to the pilot
to to our individual characters just
because it's it was amazing and there
isn't that shameful
idea around sex it's more
it's i would say it's more like we're
navigating our feelings of embarrassment
because we don't really understand what
it is but i don't really think at any
moment
we're made i guess it's different i mean
and renee you can speak more to leighton
because like she's going on her own
journey but it is there is like there
tends to be more of like a
nuanced acceptance that sex is happening
i think it's and i think you like i
completely agree with you i think i mean
i think you even still see that in
layton just in the sense of like
a lot of times not all the time by any
means but a lot of times like and this
is very real and very very real
experience for queer people but like uh
it's
it can be portrayed as um
as as someone
who's like
environment around them is not accepting
of their uh identity or sexuality or
things like that and that is very real
and happens
more than i would care to talk about but
like
uh there's also a part of with leighton
like
she's kind of
doing it to herself i'm not saying that
like she you know whatever but i think
so much is internalized and she's like
well
i don't want to be this because i don't
want that to change my identity um and i
think if she had a part of herself that
was like
it doesn't um change anything about you
that it's just inherently you and you
just need to like be graceful with like
that part of you is beautiful and as it
should be and you don't need to take on
these like outside stigmas of like what
that looks like or why that's not okay
and of course i think that stems from
familial things and in communities where
she's been and all all that but um
i think
i think it's at least for me it was nice
to
i mean it sucks but like it was nice to
see that there wasn't a character that
was like you can't do this and you can't
be this because that wasn't necessarily
my experience at all times um and it was
more similar to leighton's of like okay
well what does this mean for me and like
how does how will this change how i'm
perceived and like in spaces where i
walk in is is that gonna like read on me
now like it's gonna be a thing that's
added um so yeah i totally agree with
you pauline a guilt is guilt and shame
is something that's taught we're not
like we come out of our mother's womb
being like with our vaginas open our
dick flying out and then we're taught to
be
we're taught to be guilty and shameful
about it i think that's what bella at
least also has to deal with she's so out
about her sexuality and then there's so
many people that challenge her why are
you so sexual that means this or that
and she has to reconsider should i be
guilty should i be shameful about myself
is it something that's shameful
so that's it's something that's taught
it's not inherent in this
yeah and something that i think this
show is does interestingly is that like
maybe besides bella i think each of us
have this secret this like thing that
we're trying to keep away from each
other and this thing that we're maybe
not ashamed of but embarrassed about
like pauline said and
and we think that we're so alone in this
experience of having a messy sexual life
and like everyone else has it so
together and like i'm in this situation
i i don't know if i'm proud of but like
we're kind of all in that space
separately in different very different
ways and then coming together and trying
to like maybe cover up the fact that
we're in that situation um and i just
think it's it's funny to see how they're
all just such a mess and trying to
figure it out but they don't really know
that
god and i mean that's also so real too i
feel like that's like every sexual or
intimate experience that i had as a kid
was feeling like oh my god i'm the only
one that feels this way and like i'll
talk to y'all about certain things you'd
be like yeah 100 that happened to me too
and i'm like
so we're not alone so we're all sad you
know like it's that's real that's real
and also you always think that like
everybody has it figured out and it's
not true everybody else always thinks
that everybody else has it figured out
yeah and it's the perpetual cycle of
like what is right and it's like there
is no right you're born alone you die
alone like you live your life yeah
man
i mean pauline for your character she's
the one sort of
really kind of wanting a relationship to
go along with
the fun
so
how does that how does that work for her
she develops this crush on nikko that i
think that relationship is so cute
but
how what is that what can you say about
where that will go before the end of the
season because it seems like nothing is
going to not be i think that nico i mean
without giving anything away i think
nico is instrumental to kimberly's
um
realization
that
you can only be yourself in life
that you know you have to keep on your
own path
and
people and events are going to come in
and destabilize you and the moment where
you start veering from what you think is
correct or what how you want to be in
the world and behave is the moment where
things start to not go
um
so smoothly so i think that nico is like
it's
so incredibly impressive to kimberly
that someone
of that social class and those looks and
the frat life and all that would be
interested in like a freshman girl from
gilbert arizona
um and it she lets herself kind of fall
into that uh which i i completely
understand and i think that nico is then
very
helpful
to for kimberly to then realize what
lays ahead in life you know what to be
wary of
yeah i mean alya it seems like with your
character she's got herself in a real
mess and that like she's trying to
succeed in athletics but she's also got
herself tangled up with her coach which
those two things just can't i mean
there's just
so what can you say about where that
leaves her
during the season
well i think it leaves her in a mess
it's just a pile of [ __ ] she like really
creates it for herself i'm mad at
whitney i'm like girl stop please please
um haven't we learned but no she really
has it and i think that's a lot of the
experience of young women as well they
cling to these maybe older men or people
who seem to have it more together or or
it gives you a sense of confidence that
someone like this could be interested in
you could really desire you and you sort
of forget what it looks like and what it
actually is from the outside which could
be a little predatory which could be a
little strange
but she so desires being desired by him
she's so it gives her so much maybe it's
the rebellious nature of her this thing
she has with her mom where she just
wants to
be free and make her own decisions and
it makes her feel like more grown or
whatever it is but it really leaves her
in a mess and it i think she has to
reckon with a lot of um mistakes she
makes in a way that she really doesn't
want to she doesn't want to admit that
she's messing up she doesn't want to
admit that it's going wrong she wants to
she wants to say i have it all figured
out um and she really doesn't
renee would you say that with your
character how she presents herself and
who she is and who she knows she is
line up anymore by the end of the season
um
like physically presents herself or like
emotionally presents or both she just
just who she is the way she presents
herself to people yeah different than
who she knows she is for sure i mean i
think uh
god i mean
baby's got a long way to go she uh
really though i mean she um
i i think that i think the one really
endearing
uh quality that layton has that you kind
of see throughout the season
much more so in later episodes um she is
so damn consistent she is so consistent
which makes you
which makes you realize when she gets
into when she gets into situations like
in the women's center and like she
starts to like find people who she at
first is so judgmental um and so
rude too um she starts to realize that
she like finds comfort in those
situations obviously um
and uh so i think
i i don't necessarily think her
presentation changes you just get to see
more cracks and crevices of it um it
doesn't go away in season one um
but
you definitely see it more so throughout
and you see it in different
relationships which i love like you you
once we get into like scenes that like
we all three have like one-on-one or
like like smaller scenes like that or
smaller moments and then like scenes
that layton has with um uh
like uh people from the women's center
and things like that and these really
intimate relationships
you start to see those cracks and
crevices so you see the presentation
could be different um but you you never
get there which makes you really want it
to because you see how desperately
she wants it to be that she's just not
willing to let that go yet which like
makes my heart break because you're like
you're trying to be yourself you just
like are so in your way and if you would
allow yourself to go there
you'd be so much happier
well all right for bella how hard is it
going to be for her to continue to
figure out like she knows what she wants
and she seems to know what she needs to
do to get it but it's the other people
that seem to put those obstacles up for
her
i mean that's reality though isn't it we
all have these ideas i have these big
dreams i i'm red have all these big
dreams and there's other people
these systems of patriarchy of racism of
misogyny that are always in the way and
so she has to decide whether she wants
to be a part of this club where she has
to accept being a second class citizen
or she wants to go a different route
which often is harder and takes longer
for people of color
but maybe she can be more authentic and
true to herself as a result of that
yeah that's why i love watching your
characters because they do become that
sounding board for each other they
become that shoulder to cry on for each
other they become the person that they
can go to naked parties with yeah
and you know there aren't a lot of
people you can do all of those things
with
yeah
that was very fun that day paulie and i
had a pact and we were making sure that
if anything slips out we had each
other's backs and we were just it was
i've never seen that many balls and
[ __ ] in a room before i can say that
it's like i've seen officially seen all
shapes and sizes
well i appreciate you guys talking to me
thank you i can't wait to see the rest
of the show and you all are fabulous so
thanks so much oh thank you